there are scenes in this film that I
love where the two of you are just kind
of like going at each other like
throwing barbs back and forth is that
all scripted stuff or is that you know
from your experience of working together
things that you've kind of bottled up
that you're like now is the time no
luckily luckily most of that was
scripted you know we had some really
great writers who kind of know how to
create that back and forth that kind of
Han Solo Princess Leia reparte but but
that's the beauty of a movie like this
that even when they're arguing it's kind
of flirting you know what I mean that
that's the beauty of that Dynamic um
Anna and I know each other so well
um I think if we were just left to our
own devices I don't know if much of it
would be scripted
concept of you know a lot of moves that
we've seen you in you're just like
making stuff happen beating people up
left right and center and it's really
fun to watch you kind of bumble through
a few things every now and again
unexpectedly really fun to watch right
do the reflexes kind of kick in to be
like okay I know how to do this in an
action scene and you have to really bad
no God no this was so nice it's movies
like this where you get to be the eyes
of the audience you know you're the one
who's incapable you're the one who's
panicking and that's certainly what I
would be doing in situations like this
so it was nice to kind of not try to be
heroic yeah
until the end yeah we all have that
moment
um I love seeing you
take a lot of ass in this shoot a lot of
guns take out a lot of bad guys it feels
like a nice preview as well for
ballerina which is going to be a very
exciting thing
um I'm curious about is it do you feel
like every time you did a new scene you
were stepping up your action game and
learning new things
um
um I mean maybe yeah I mean it was a it
was a it was a lot of work in that sense
for me in in this one and every scene
did feel maybe because I was getting
tired you know more and more tired
throughout the movie but but it felt
like we were we were definitely it was
getting more complicated and the more I
did maybe the stun team thought that I
could do even more like they kept
pushing me
um and it was but it was a lot of fun it
was very enjoyable it was uh I don't
know maybe because of the tone of the
movie also I didn't have
some I so much pressure with the action
and I could also like put some fun into
it as well and it wasn't yeah
um yeah having worked together uh a
handful of times before doing this are
there things about each other that you
would warn each other about about
getting ghosted like is there anything
that you would say to Chris that you'd
be like listen I know that you love this
particular type of music but you can't
let someone know because they're not
gonna oh I see if I'm getting ghosted um
well I mean I don't know if I could
make sure you say please and thank you
otherwise that guy he's out of there uh
no I don't know now she could probably
warn me about a million that's not true
either yeah debatable
I think for me this movie with
everything in it like all the action all
the great cameos everything that's
fantastic about it the most unbelievable
part to me was the fact that you
literally walked up to her and was like
Hey I want to go on a date with you like
nobody does that in 2023 it's all online
it's all over you know Tinder whatever
you call it
um is this something that you could
still do in your life like if you know
you're going out there on the street
today and you met the woman of your
dreams or the man of your dreams would
you be like Hey listen ah I feel like we
got something
hmm I mean I think I would yeah I think
I would I think being you know 40 or you
know you understand what it feels like
to like the the windows open and close
you know and I mean I think in your
youth you can let nerves you know kind
of hold you back but that
at this age you're like ah just go up
and say Hello I would be more nervous if
having a conversation or or a
relationship with someone online that I
don't really really know or feel who
this person is is so much about the
energy and the vibe and and looking at
each other I don't think I would I don't
I've never done it and I don't think
yeah no no no no no you can't I need to
know
yeah I need to know yeah well I mean
along that no you know 40 getting over
40 Windows doors open and close SNL
it's right there I know I just I just I
I not funny I'm not a funny person I'm
not and maybe I only feel that because I
I have very very funny friends who've
almost told me I'm not a funny person
and you know it's funny in this movie
you're funny funny you're Chris maybe if
I'm maybe if I well listen laughing at
me is different than laughing with me
um but but you know if I'm if I'm
scripted to death maybe but even still I
just I know how I would feel it would
just be an everyday anxiety constant
regret why did I do this I could have
just been comfortable at my house in my
bed not worrying about this so uh listen
power to you good luck
now I have regrets
report back on guys I'm not sure